est ce que tu as déjà été en prison en
garde à vue non
j'ai vu ton histoire termes là je suis
personne tu as compris ici on est tous
personne publique petit et mais je vais
avoir besoin de ton aide à l'extérieur
pour faire quoi
grdf
j'ai quelque chose qui va te plaire tu
connais la valeur de leurs quatre
millions et demi intraçable qu'est ce
que tu aimes vraiment honteux des great
quelqu'un rentre à dans les communes
hier ces singes devra menacé avec son
pistolet et c qui laisse un beau père de
clara alors
c'est de leur ensemble et ça paye
on sens prêt pour une petite séance de
sexe
rayon mai
les champs
eh oui monsieur mais ça c'est un
combattant